je précise d'abord que évidemment ce
qu'il a fait est terrible il a pris sa
voiture en ayant consommé des
stupéfiants c'est tout ce qu'on sait
pour l'instant maintenant j'ai depuis
l'impression d'insister à l'encharge et
vous savez ça me fait beaucoup brosser
est-ce que vous vous rappelez qui Agnone
c'est-à-dire quand les partisans les
plus cinglés de Trump en gros se sont
mis à diffuser des messages expliquant
et beaucoup le croyaient que le monde
est dirigé par une élite pédophile
sataniste c'est la décadence le sexe la
drogue on mélange tout on mélange ce qui
est autorisé ce qu'il n'est pas on
mélange ce qu'on sait et ce qu'on ne
sait pas si vous voulez les conditionnel
en ce qui concerne l'affaire des vidéos
pédopornographiques ça ne va pas on ne
devrait même pas en parler là j'ai
l'impression que Palmade si vous
laissez-le le le mal absolu c'est le
nouveau diable si vous voulez il est
attaqué de partout franchement attaquer
Palma donc on a pas besoin d'être très
courageux aujourd'hui